des tribunes pleines à craquer un grand
show à l'américaine et les meilleurs
pilotes mondiaux de bmx sur la piste un
cocktail qui a permis à la première
manche de la coupe du monde d'afficher
complet ce samedi 31 mars et ce dimanche
1er avril au vélotour national avec plus
de 10000 spectateurs
c'est assez sympa c'est les gens peuvent
être assez proche de la piste et du coup
c'est assez participatif
on peut approcher les compétiteurs alors
on peut voir les grands pilotes français
s'affronter avec les meilleurs européens
et et pilotes internationaux donc ça
fait plaisir de les voir au niveau quoi
un succès populaire inédit pour la
france- qui n'avait plus accueilli de
manche coupe du monde depuis sept ans un
vrai plus pour les pilotes tricolores
selon leurs stars ça nous fait toujours
un immense plaisir de courir à domicile
c'est à ça une saveur un peu
particulière donc donc oui je dirais que
oui on a un petit comme on dit en
anglais rom advantage le pilote qui est
le plus profité de cet avantage à
domicile c'est lui joris daudet le
pilote du stade bordelais 2 fois
vainqueur de la couronne mondiale en
2011 et 2016 a terminé troisième de la
première manche le samedi et 1er 24
heures plus tard suis vraiment content
de gagner ici à la maison à paris
c'est vraiment exceptionnel le public
est exceptionnel tout le week end encore
merci à et j'espère qu'on aura une autre
coupe du monde ici en france ' l'année
prochaine avant de penser à l'année
prochaine et un possible retour de la
compétition à saint quentin en yvelines
les pilotes mondiaux s'affronteront les
5 et 6 mai aux pays bas pour la deuxième
manche de la coupe du monde